show me the hardest part isn't making
your first movie it's making your second
movie because your first movie you have
you have all your hopes and dreams and
all the hoods fun everything in the you
know you have you have all that energy
and your movies never going to be as
good as you envisioned it and it's
probably not gonna be as successful as
you envisioned it because you know it's
the movie business is a business and the
people at the top have been doing it for
30 years and that's that their movies
are really good because of that because
I've been doing it and they're very
successful so you have all that coming
down on you while you try to make a
second movie so instead of just having
the fear of is this any good or what not
and all that all those kind of fears for
your second maybe you also have e well
is it gonna be more sick is it going to
be more stressful than think I just did
is it is you know obviously I went out
into the world and the world showed me
what they thought of me and I don't know
it sounds very harsh but they showed me
what the movie was and now I'm trying to
jump over that hurdle to so that's what
you know to me it's like okay you make
your second movie you're really okay
you're a filmmaker does that make sense
do you think that then people are truly
doing it for themselves maybe the world
showed somebody what they thought of
them and it wasn't the applause that
people were expecting and then they
still have that thing them or they want
to continue all of it and is that really
when you truly do it for yourself yeah I
mean you know it's uh it's the I don't I
say that's where I that's where I go
okay you're a filmmaker cuz you're okay
with it's not just a dream it's not just
a fantasy I want this life of like oh
I'm the famous filmmaker and I have all
this money and all this stuff it's okay
you're clearly doing this for some other
reason then then success per se as an
terms of how we define it and
financially or whatever or whatever you
defined a success because you didn't get
that success for safe obviously people
some people do with their first films
but the vast majority of is don't so
that's I hope they did that answer your
question yeah and do you think then in
term that can make someone turn that
corner it's a possibly getting closer to
success then yeah I mean that's I mean
that's a lot you know that's we always
have that that dream or per se you know
that's the perception of hollow they
made their first film and and all that
stuff and the reality is almost all of
us we make our first film is that no one
sees even like really famous directors i
have a friend marc staal rafi that's a
no budget thing he always uses
Christopher Nolan as an example because
everyone thinks Christopher Nolan's
first film was following know his first
film he'd ever even finished you know uh
so you know that's that's where you turn
that corner yeah it's a great example
and it also it's very inspiring because
it's like oh okay there's people who are
extremely successful when it's like oh
yeah they never they first felt you know
they had to learn how to be good why
which everybody does and it's
storytelling it's like one of the most
advanced state you know even telling
stories since before written language
and people think Oh movies there's new
and it's only been a hundred years it's
like no storytelling it's so complex
that there's no way you're gonna make a
first film you know there's no way your
first thing is gonna really be that
great for you I mean it might be great
but you could probably do much better
ten years from now when you really
learned how to form what you're trying
to say and then realized the tools and
tricks of storytelling
you